Jacob Shulman, thank you
for being on 20 Minute Leaders.
Hi Michael, very nice being here.
I am so excited to learn about
what it means to be the CFO
of multiple companies,
very very well-known companies,
Mellanox, JFrog most recently,
an incredible company
here in Silicon Valley.
And I'm especially curious to hear
and to learn as a young entrepreneur,
what are the responsibilities
and the different mindsets
that one needs to come with when working
as the chief financial officer,
because I don't know finances.
I don't know what that even entails.
You raised over $750 million in capital.
You've managed or and you've seen
over $1.5 billion in acquisitions.
I mean these are just
astonishing numbers.
Jacob, let's just start.
Who are you?
I don't know. Looks like I'm a simple guy
that trying to achieve my dream career
and enjoy all the way through it.
So what is that dream career
that you're talking about?
I always wanted to be involved in business
and work along
very bright entrepreneurs,
helping them to achieve their goals.
My background is in finance
and I enjoy that side of the business.
As you know, entrepreneurs many time they,
technology is, they're very bright guys,
but they less, let's say,
knowledgeable in finance
and scalability.
How to run the businesses
and back offices of corporations.
Right. I mean
when I think about entrepreneurs,
I think of these crazy people
who run up and down the hallway
screaming about the strategy
and what we should be doing
but they're not necessarily connected
to the financial spreadsheets
that it takes to then run
a successful business
that can raise capital through the rounds.
It's not just financial spreadsheets.
It's entire back office, right?
How to build a scalable processes.
How to consider different decisions.
Would it make sense to raise capital now?
Or maybe wait until the product is ready
and raise later
at a higher valuation?
All of this decision that
I'm helping them to take.
So, yeah, because I think that
one of the interesting phenomena
that I'm observing is that
the millions of dollars that people
are talking about in venture funding,
it's almost become
like just meaningless numbers.
Like yeah, I raised six million.
Oh, maybe I could raise 10 million.
And you're talking about
the different finances of a company,
and it almost seems to lose the meaning
of what is that money actually
being used for.
So it sounds like,
is your position really understanding
the core of the company
and understanding how much money
we actually need
and how are we actually going to use it?
Yes, absolutely.
So first of all, what's our needs, right?
Right.
What runway we want to get.
But also what our core business
and what value we could get
for that business, right?
Yes, many times it's valuation
it's very subjective.
But at the end,
there are some substantial business
behind that, right.
So how do you combine these
to your needs, your valuation,
and what's true business behind that?
This is something that I help.
So, give me the day to day of a CFO.
I'm observing.
I talk to a lot of founders
and entrepreneurs
and I see how they operate,
but I've never really shadowed a CFO
of a huge company
like Mellanox or JFrogs.
Share with me.
You come to the office in the morning,
what do you care about?
What keeps you up at night?
First of all, when I wake up,
first thing is to check
how the futures of the market look...
To see what's gonna happen today
in the market.
And especially if you see
... a public company.
Many times a company's shares move
irrespective of the company business.
Different drivers behind the share price.
But at the end,
every employee of public company,
when they come to work,
they open the ... finance and they see,
"Okay, uh-oh, what's going on
with the company?
The company's share is
down five percent, up five percent" Right.
Is that a big thing?
When you're an executive
in a public company that you go
and you are constantly checking
Yahoo Finance to see
what the stock price is?
Not constantly checking,
but you do want to have an idea
what's going on today in the market
because many times investors might call
if it's a significant movement
in the stock, right
So if the stock,
what's a significant movement
for example?
I'd say more than five percent.
People would want to understand why.
What's the reasons for that, right?
And especially,
if you have a very good relationship
with investors,
they might call you and ask,
"Hey, what's going on with the company?"
Right?
What is it that's triggering?
What are the trigger in this movement
in the stock?
So, you could come to the office
and you see like there's a five percent
increase or decrease
and you just get a phone call and say,
"Hey, I saw we just lost
a few billion dollars here.
Can you explain, like,
is there anything wrong?"
Yeah. So, many times you know
different investors,
they look at the time horizon.
Time horizon is different.
Some guys, they don't really
they don't care about daily movements
because they invest for the long term.
And some guys
they have much shorter view.
So, this is obviously the way
how you choose investors in your business.
Who you contacted.
What investors you target.
That's very important.
So, Jacob,
what is your biggest contribution
to the company?
So, as the CFO,
what is the top three things
that you provide that without you
the company would not be able to continue
as it's doing today?
So, first of all, I think my primary role
is to help the CEO of the company
to understand
where we stand with our financials,
what's the true performance
of our business,
and what investments,
additional investments,
we can allow ourselves
to make to grow the business,
and what are those areas
where we could invest
to help, to get the best ROI.
That's I think, that's the primary role
because, as you know,
CEOs they're very busy people.
They drive the product,
they drive marketing,
they try to close deals.
And many times
they don't have time and capacity
to have that view.
So that's what my primary role.
Second, I obviously help a lot with
running the back office of the company.
The company, when you run
the company, a lot of law
that you have to comply with.
There is different regulations, etc.
This is something
that I help with as well,
because I want the business side,
the CEO to focus on the business.
Right.
Those are my main areas.
And obviously being the,
contacting major stakeholders
such as investors and all of that stuff.
So, that's the governance side
of the company
and this is something also
that I'm helping with.
How connected are you
to the mission of the company?
So, how connected are you
to the mission of Mellanox?
To the mission of JFrog?
Rather than the financial projections
of where the company could get to?
And I'm talking, when I say mission,
I'm talking about, you know,
Google's mission is to connect
to the world's information.
Like those types of missions.
Are you there with the executive teams?
Of course. Of course.
This is, as executive in the company,
you have to believe
in the mission of the company.
You have to, otherwise
there's no place for you
in the company.
If you don't believe in the mission,
you're a leader in the company.
Right.
It's not just you accountant, and seeds,
and calculates income and expenses.
No, not at all.
You're a leader in the company,
you drive the company forward
and if you don't believe in the mission,
or far away from
understanding the mission,
then there's no way for you
you have to be in the company.
Totally. Totally.
Okay. So, talk to me a little bit about
why you enjoy being the CFO
I am a numbers guy
but I'm not a huge economics guy.
I am much more, I think, in the realm of
the engineering side of things.
Why CFO? Why leading
the financials of the companies?
First of all, I think my background
fits me very well for this position
but this is something that
I always was attracted to.
The financial side, right.
The investment side, the ROI.
I'm less maybe creative
on the engineering side,
although I do have
some engineering background.
But, with time
I develop these capabilities
of truly understanding
the financial future of the company.
For me just to take a look
at the financials,
I know what's going on right away.
Right?
So, this is something that I enjoy.
And this is something
that I feel comfortable with
to read that side of the business.
Are those similar lessons
and understandings
as what investors need
in order to invest Series B onwards
as you're able to actually look
at the details of the numbers?
Obviously investors in public companies
and VC investors,
they're completely different considerations
that they make.
When a public company investors
reviews the financials,
they typically could value the company
on certain history
of the company performance, right?
Financial performance.
VC investors
they many times
they don't even have
any history of the company, right
Investors, VC investors they many time
just invest into the idea,
and into the entrepreneur,
versus the public investors
where they typically invest
into the business,
already established business,
Comparing how they performed.
Comparing their success in the market
and then projecting what will be
their future success.
That makes a lot of sense.
And, I still wanna know the
you're seeing the companies grow.
What is the most fun thing you take away
from seeing these companies grow?
Is it more of the early stages,
the later stages?
'cause most of your experience is
in the later stages, right?
I joined Mellanox when they were just
$50 million in revenues.
Wow.
And I saw this growth.
When I left Mellanox, they were over
a billion dollar in revenues,
and 3,000 employes.
So, obviously I saw that growth.
And it's obviously at different stages,
you have to deal with different issues.
Right?
When it's smaller company,
less established company,
you really try to penetrate
into the market.
To build those processes
that allow to scale fast
if you're successful.
When you're a large company, you deal with a lot
with management of the company.
Coordination.
Maybe acquiring other companies and
integrating them into the business.
So, it's at different stages
you have different needs.
So, and as you're going
through these different companies
and different incredible experiences,
what are some of the patterns
that you're seeing in terms of
healthy ways of running finances?
There maybe unhealthy ways of doing that.
I mean, things that I could take with me
as an entrepreneur moving forward
when I run my own business.
What are the most critical things
I should keep in mind besides
bringing on a very very good CFO?
Critical things is, first of all,
it's all about people, right?
People you work with,
the integrity of your CEO.
I would never want to work
with someone who does some shady deals
or anything like that.
So, integrity is a big part of it.
It's honesty and integrity.
That's very important
because we all come to work to enjoy,
and I don't want to have sleepless nights
just thinking what might happen, right,
if my partners decide,
"Hey, maybe we'll do cut that corner
or that corner."
No. No. No.
So, this is all about people first.
And second, obviously,
truly, I enjoy working
with true professionals, right,
they're passionate about their business.
Totally. As a CEO or as an entrepreneur,
does the CFO, will the same person
usually fit the role as the company grows?
Because I imagine that
you probably would get a CFO, I guess,
when you're, I don't know,
Series B, maybe, in the company?
And then you're growing and you eventually
you're gonna go public, hopefully.
And you're gonna have perhaps
a billion dollars in revenue.
That's a very different
transactional amount
from raising $30 million to getting now,
to getting a $100 million a year.
Is it usually the same person
who can handle both?
Or do you usually see people
shifting, changing CFOs?
It depends. It depends on the person.
Many people just enjoy working
with smaller companies,
and when the company
reaches a certain level,
then they just decide to leave
and go back to smaller companies.
Same true for other guys
who enjoy working for big companies.
There are some people like me
enjoy to see
all the way through grow, right
And many times you just
grow with the company
and you use a lot of common sense.
Totally. Totally.
Talk to me a little bit
about this idea of seeing big growth
as a strategy versus getting bottled up
in the current finances.
So, you're looking at financial statements
in the back office and what's happening,
but you also have to imagine
what's possible for the company
to achieve one day.
So, how do you balance the two?
And what are the ways that you are able
to then think about the big picture?
Yeah. So, obviously, you have to analyze
the size of your market,
your potential, your competition
what they could take.
So, a lot of "what if" scenarios
that you build in,
a lot of different projections
that you're trying to build and see,
Hey, what makes sense?
How big could it be,
and what makes sense
to invest today to get there?
Right.
Versus maybe,
just milking the existing market.
But that's something
that's changing all the time, right?
I mean, looking at your market,
looking at you competition.
On a strategic level,
yeah, you have to do that
every so often, right?
Typically on the strategic side,
things don't change every day, right?
But you definitely have to go
through this exercise
every so often to see
because different markets
change at different pace, right
If you're in a very very fast
changing market,
then you have to do it much faster
versus maybe established markets
with not many players, then maybe
you don't have to do that that often.
Yeah. Is it a very scary job
what you're doing?
I mean, managing,
'cause at the end, it sounds to me,
like you are the backbone of the company.
Always, the company
can look at you and say,
"Jacob, are we good? Are we good?"
"Yeah, we're good. We're good."
And you're the one
that's keen on all the numbers.
You know what's gonna happen in a month.
You're projecting
what's gonna happen in year.
It sounds like a lot of responsibility,
honestly.
I'm still learning how to manage
my own finances properly.
You're managing billions of dollars.
So, is it scary sometimes?
No, it's not.
Obviously, I have to be
properly prepared for that.
Right.
And it all comes with experience.
Obviously, now, today,
I feel much more comfortable in my job
versus my first CFO job
when I got when I was 32, right?
That was a bit scary.
What was that like?
What is it?
What was that like
getting your first CFO at 32
and for the first time
running the -
You have huge weight on your shoulders
and that kind of weighs on you, right?
And to make decisions
knowing that you are the last one
who makes decision
and the business will perform
based on your decision,
that's something that
you have to get used to.
How did that turn out at the end?
That was very successful.
You know that my first CFO job,
I joined a company
that was going through
some sort of restructuring.
And, it was at the end
a very successful restructuring.
The company turned profitable.
And it was very good exercise
for me to understand,
to get my hands dirty in different things.
Incredible. So, you've seen growth
at Mellanox from 50 million a year
to a billion a year.
JFrog also,
fast fast fast growing company.
Is that really where your excitement is
in the fast growing companies?
Oh, yeah, of course.
You want to come to the office
and deal with different things, right?
Every day.
And I'm not the person who's waiting to do
their routine stuff everyday.
So, the company that grow
and present those opportunities,
and that's what excites me.
So, if you have to give
some financial advice,
and obviously you're not supposed to give
financial advice informally,
but if you were to give financial advice
strategically to young entrepreneurs
that are starting their businesses,
or even entrepreneurs
who have now raised their series A
and are moving forward,
what are the most important things
that the CEO should keep in mind
given your knowledge of the CFO position?
Yeah. Always be frugal.
Frugal. Okay.
Don't throw away money
when you don't need to
because markets are volatile,
our economic environment is very unstable.
So, just cash is king.
I don't say don't invest,
but know where you invest.
What's your expectation
from that investment.
And just don't throw money.
Right.
I mean, when you deal
with these sums of money,
how granular does a company get?
I mean, when you're talking about
a $100 million deal,
I always thought to myself,
I remember I even asked a friend
when I was younger.
You buy a house for,
let's say, $500,000.
What if you could just ask,
like if you were to go to that dealer and say,
"Hey, can you give me a $500 discount
on the house?"
They would say, "Yes" right
Nobody would cancel the deal.
Yet, in our day to day lives,
we think a lot before we spend $500.
So, and in the same realm, I'm thinking
when you have a $100 million deal
and you've seen those deals,
how granular do people get
about the millions?
Or is it just
okay, let's just round it up
to the next nicest number
and make everybody happy?
I think at any deal,
it all depends on the materiality, right?
Okay.
Deal of $500, $100 is material
to that deal.
Right.
But in deal of $500 million dollars,
$100 is nothing, right?
So, really,
when you focus on material things
and not just on pennies
that's what helps you
to think strategically.
On the other hand,
my accounting department,
when they reconcile bank accounts,
they have to go to pennies, right?
And this is what I expect from them.
Sure. Okay no that make sense.
It really depends on the role
and depends on the materiality of the deal.
I'm sure. I'm sure.
Jacob, before we leave,
I have to ask you
the most important question.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Future.
Because future, I always think,
try to think, several years ahead.
That's something that guides me.
And that's why future, you know different people
live in different time, right
Some people live in present.
Yeah.
I'm always thinking about future.
Present is less concern me.
I always kind of think few steps ahead.
Amazing.
That's what it is.
I think the second would be fun
because we spend so much time at work.
And I'd like to do what I like to do
and to have fun with that, right
And third, I don't know,
maybe different experiences.
Because other than work,
you have your life going on, right?
So you want to enjoy the life as well.
Work is very important component
of my life,
but I have various interest
other than work.
I love it.
I did not expect those three words
from a really really accomplished CFO.
I always love being surprised.
But, Jacob, thank you very much
for the time.
Thank you for your inspiration
and for teaching me.
We didn't even talk about J-Ventures
and early stage investing,
but we'll leave that for another time.
But thank you very much.
Thank you, Michael,
very much for having me.
Take care. Bye bye.
Bye bye.